The truth is these foods are designed to be over-consumed and without
telling consumers how these foods are gonna, um, you know,
affect their behavior when they try to moderate their consumption of these pita
chips or the pint of ice cream.
And they end up feeling like moral failures because they just simply can't that
I think is where the problem lies.
So for most of us then that, uh,
that know that Alzheimer's and dementia that these numbers seem to be increasing
and increasing. And your mom, you said 59 was 58, 58 years old. I mean,
that's incredibly young.
So let's talk about some of those things that you can do before they,
before you're sitting at the doctor's office and they're giving you the 10
medications.
Well, yeah, yeah. I mean,
the first thing that you need to realize is that dementia often begins in the
brain decades before the first symptom.
And I saw that nobody was talking about this and that's why I decided to step
up, you know, I, it, it,
didn't the fact that I wasn't a medical doctor to me didn't seem like a barrier
to entry because I genuinely believe that people should know how to care for
their bodies and their brains. And we're just not taught this. Um,
we're fed misinformation from every conceivable angle,
whether it's the food industry and the way that they market their foods, uh,
making health claims on their products to the way that, uh, the media, um,
reports on, on health studies and research and things like that.
So I think, I mean, what I've learned is that you really,
uh, that the, the, the standard American diet is toxic essentially.
And anything that you can do to run in the opposite direction.
So what is the standard American diet, if you're painting that picture,
what does that really look like? There are.
There are images that you can, like,
you can go to Google images and you can search for the average, uh, you know,
shopping hall for your typical American family over the course of a week.
And essentially it's all processed foods, um, ultra processed foods to be,
to be more clear today,
60% of the calories that we're consuming come from what are called ultra ultra
processed foods, um, which are made in factories.
They usually are the processed permutations of wheat, corn, and rice,
maybe some soy.
And they generally are what food scientists refer to as being
hyper palatable. So they they're extremely calorie dense.
They're not satiating. In fact,
they actually can make you hunger hungry later on.
They often put additives in there, right. That actually make you want more,
right. Isn't that the Dorito effect or something?
Yeah. I mean,
these foods are just they're they're they become impossibly delicious when you
combine sugar, fat, salt, um, you know, these are,
I mean,
each of these flavors were relatively scarce in antiquity and
today they're just abundantly available.
Like sugar would be available to a Hunter gatherer, you know,
once per year, when it was summer and the fruit, you know, became ripe. Um,
and even then the,
the fruits that would be available to one of our ancestors would be a fraction
as sweet as they are today.
Right?
The amount apples that you would have to eat to get the sugar levels that you
can get in a bag of sour patch kids or something.
Like the ancestral, Apple is like a crab Apple, essentially. And today they're,
you know, we have like these cosmic crisp apples that are amazing. Like,
don't get me wrong. I'm a huge fan of, of apples,
but they're bred to contain more starch and sugar than ever before in any in
history. And they're also bread.
A lot of our produce now is being bred to remove these bitter compounds,
which are actually compounds that probably produce the greatest health benefit
when we consume them like polyphenols and flavonoids and things like that. Um,
so sugar fat we know is, is highly delectable. Uh, you know, I mean,
it sends off, um, our, our, you know, brain's reward centers.
Like it's one of the reasons why we put half and half in our coffee.
It just allows flavors to linger on the tongue. Um, and then salt, you know,
the word salary derives from salt. It was, uh,
it was something that was it's super important. You know,
we need it for good health. Um, sodium is a macro mineral.
It's also one of these nutrients has been demonized over the past couple of
decades, but you combine them all together.
And it's basically like the 4th of July fireworks in the brain and it makes it
impossible to moderate our consumption of these foods. And so one of the,
one of the ideas that I put forth in the genius life,
I try to really make dietary recommendations without further harming people's
relationship with food.
I think people today have this fractured relationship with food.
I always see what, uh, when I'm at trader Joe's, they have guilt-free, uh,
pita chips. And I'm always like the fact that the world,
the word guilt is on there.
Like if like the idea that you'd be buying a regular pita chip and feel guilty
about it is kind of crazy putting aside whether you want carbs or breads or
whatever, but like the way it's all marketed guilt, these are guilt free.
So you can walk out of here and you're not going to feel guilty.
Like that's not the stuff you should feel guilty over it.
Oh, it's ridiculous. I mean,
the truth is these foods are designed to be over-consumed and without
telling consumers how these foods are gonna, um, you know,
affect their behavior when they try to moderate their consumption of these pita
chips or the pint of ice cream.
And they end up feeling like moral failures because they,
they just simply can't that I think is where the problem lies.
On the other hand, if you actually are aware that these foods, um, you know,
they're so easily over consumed, uh, then it,
it becomes informed consent, you know,
then you actually know what you're opting into,
and then there shouldn't be any guilt about that. You're just making it,
you're an adult making a decision, which you should be able to do.
You should be able to eat whatever you want.
But the problem is I think that most people don't know that these foods actually
drive over consumption. There was a great study that was published. And I,
I wrote about what these hyper palatable ultra processed foods do to our
behavior in genius foods. But since genius foods came out,
there was a great study that was published. Um,
it actually was funded by the national institutes of health,
and they found that when people were given, um,
all you can eat access to an ultra processed diet,
it's called ad libitum feeding that people tend to over consume about 500
additional calories, uh, to reach the point of satiety.
So to just eat until to a point of fullness,
people tend to over consume about 500 calories a day.
And you're more inclined to do that by eating process,
just because of the way they're making you feel.
Bagels, muffins, pizzas, burritos, chicken dishes, um,
potato chips sandwiches, things like that. You know, the foods that are,
that are primarily, uh, package shelf, stable, um,
devoid of moisture, which actually can, can, um,
be satiating when food has water in it. But, you know, water is a,
it makes food spoil it.
Like you have to remove the water to make a product shelf stable.
So they're not satiating. They can often induce what's called by phasic hunger.
So they can make you hungry later on. And yeah,
500 additional calories of that a day that might not seem like a lot,
but stretched out over the course of a week. That's a pound of fat gain. Um,
and then they, so it was a crossover study. And when they put these same people,
when they gave them access to foods that were minimally processed, again,
ad libitum feeding, they were able to eat until they were full. Um,
to the same degree of satiety,
they actually under consumed about 300 calories a day.
So what that's going to do is lead to effortless weight loss.
So that's really kind of like the switch that I think people need to,
people need to be aware of that. You know, we,
we tend to think that we have full agency when it comes to our meal choices,
but we don't. I mean, we're, um, our actions are the end result of,
of an interplay between hormones, neurotransmitters,
which are ultimately influenced by the types of foods that we're eating.
More than anything else, though. You're always as someone that cares about this,
and you're trying to get people to change their habits.
It's really always about fighting a marketing machine that is oddly ahead of
you. So like,
if you just turn on television and every commercial you see for like a breakfast
food, suddenly they try to make everything healthy. But you know,
it's like an egg that you're cracking this thing.
And then it's got all this other stuff already in there and it's sorta seems
healthy. You're kind of like, Oh, I'm eating an egg in the morning.
And it kind of seems right.
And then I'm sure that when you look at the instructions or the, uh,
ingredients on the back, it's like, yeah, the sodium and everything else, but,
but you have to fight that constantly because they're marketing it all as
helping.
Yeah. I mean, food marketing, it's, uh, you know, they,
they put products at eye level, they market to children, you know,
they get those they've, they've forged those habits early in life.
They become exponentially more difficult to break. Um, but yeah, I mean,
I think it's, I'm human. So I had processed foods too, right? Like, I'm,
I'm just as guilty as anybody else. But I think to be aware, I mean,
knowledge is power at the end of the day.
And to be able to act on that knowledge. I mean, that's the most empowering, um,
aspect of all of this, because you know,
like health is something that health care is something that we,
that we do. And we're like pushing the shopping cart through the, you know,
the aisles of the supermarket actually avoiding the aisles because that's where
all the ultra processed foods tend to tend to be. And, you know,
when we're debating with ourselves, whether or not to get to the gym, um,
that's really where healthcare happens.
What I with my mom was sick care and the relative lack of options.
Once you actually have one of these like chronic diseases that has set in.
And so at the end of the day, the food industry doesn't have your back.
Um, I mean the food industry is great in many, it's not.
It's an industry. It's not all bad. I mean, food is.
Food is safer, you know, we're,
we're exposed if you were pathogens than ever before. Um, you know,
the hunger is less of an issue today than it is in the past if you're in the
developed world, the developed world,
but a lot of these conditions that we're seeing society now struggle with her
lifestyle mediated, they're mediated by, um, being, you know,
overly sedentary by basing our diet around these ultra processed foods. And.
You know, it's funny, I'm noticing now at whole foods,
just because we're in the midst of this odd thing with Corona virus,
that nobody, at least at my whole foods,
nobody's touching the grains that you can do yourself. You know,
they've got that wall of grains. It's like,
nobody's even going over there anymore, which is probably I guess,
good at the moment, but you know, who does?
Yeah. A lot of people are now using these hand sanitizers, if you like,
go on Amazon, it's there, the markup has just shot up exponentially.
Um, but something that I think few people appreciate is that when you use a hand
sanitizer, before you go shopping,
and then you touch the store register receipt,
the store register receipts are actually coded with bisphenol a,
which is a pretty potent endocrine disruptor that hand sanitizer,
when you use it just before,
or even just after you touched these receipts that actually dramatically,
by at least an order of magnitude increases, um,
the permeability of your skin to these companies.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.